we've got Anna Sabri the Conservative MP
to step into the breach for us because
in the space of three days Theresa May
has gone from the unquestionable
figurehead of the Conservative Party set
for five years of steady rule to a
lonely Prime Minister isolated in number
10 just about captain float by an angry
party and perhaps there are few angry
within that party then Anna Supra who
joins us now from Nottingham hello thank
you for being with us and Anna Cibrian I
think I'm angry at how are you feeling
then describe your feelings to us I
think you know obviously when those
results came in on Friday there was a
sense of real concern and a bit of anger
there because some very good colleagues
had gone and it just seems such a
terrible terrible shame we are where we
are now we've got to have some stability
in our government and people have got to
get behind the government and Teresa's
got to broaden her base and she's got to
listen to people and especially she's
got to listen to business and all parts
of our country and all parts of our
party as well so our people she may have
to listen to our DP if they are going to
effectively prop up the Conservatives
and give them that magic number needed
to get a majority how do you feel about
the idea of the Conservative Party going
into an agreement with another party who
are against abortion and against
same-sex marriage
I missed the last bit of your question
but I get your drift Sophie let me make
it very clear I have friends in the DUP
I get on well with them I don't agree
with their policies on abortion gay
rights at all in fact I absolutely
detest those policies but I think we can
come together for the national good
looking especially at the economy
there's nothing wrong with doing that
because at the end of the day the
national interest must be the primary
interest we need now to consider all
those things we need to put stability
especially as we enter these brexit
negotiations and if the DUP are prepared
to vote for a Queen's Speech that is a
sensible Queen's Speech and a good
budget I don't have a difficulty with
that they don't I don't have to sign up
to all their other stuff which I don't
agree with at all even with DP Theresa
may only will have a handful of MPs a
couple of MPs as a majority all it will
take for example is you and Kane can't
go out for lunch together and suddenly
she's going to have to you know make
different compromises on breakfast to
get it through the houses of Commons do
you think she's got a majority for
leaving a single market in the house cut
I'm so sorry but you just cut out at I'm
saying do you think Theresa May has a
majority in parliament for leaving the
single market no I don't think she does
have a majority in the House of Commons
for leaving the single market but
actually what's more important I don't
think people out here in the real world
actually want the hard rec set that had
been put forward and I don't think they
liked this no deal is better than a bad
deal people want a good deal and that
may include membership of the single
market certainly will include membership
with a customs union and of course this
will solve so many of the problems
notably actually in Northern Ireland
you see membership of the single market
membership of the customs union actually
solves those really serious problems
over the border and it will it's what
British business wants as well they do
not want this hard brexit and you see if
Teresa starts to listen to people and if
she starts to work with people and
embrace people
in then I believe we can get the brexit
deal that is in the interests of
everybody in our country and especially
that younger generation and I think have
voted in this election and made their
own views very clear now you've had a
couple of days to reflect on it just how
bad were those election results for your
party and do you think the reason they
can realistically carry on well III
think her position is in the long term
untenable and it's with regret who knows
when the first people to come out and
support Teresa but the election result
where she would her name on the campaign
means that I just can't see how she can
continue in any with any long term in
any long-term way I think she will have
to go unfortunately but not for some
time let's get this clear we need
stability we need to put you that's that
that sense of of the economy and our
country and the nation's interests
absolutely at the forefront and there's
messing about behind the scenes she's
got to open up as I say big more
consensual in the way that she operates
listen to people like Philip Hammond and
Greg Clark who represent business so
well in the cabinet and if she does
those things then she can lay down the
way for her to leave and then we will
have a new prime minister actually the
last thing we want there's a general
election I think the British people
would be appalled at that prospect and
indeed can I make it very clear I'm not
for one moment saying that we are going
back on the EU referendum result my
sense certainly in my constituency which
voted 48 49 percent to remain in the EU
people have accepted the result like I
have and they now want us to get a good
breaks it deal they accept we're leaving
the EU that's not a harder exit they've
rejected that now you say that to resume
will have to go at some stage who do you
think could potentially step in I mean
there's a lot of talk about Boris
Johnson in the papers today I'm
absolutely not answering that question
I'm not playing that game of speculating
I know it's great fun for the
commentators and of course you're right
to ask the question but I'm afraid I'm
not playing that game
at all I'm afraid that the situation we
are in is far more serious than us all
having a bit of fun about whether it's
this candid or that candidate at the
moment is Teresa may we need to get that
stability and we need to do the right
thing for our country how disappointing
but I perhaps was not totally surprised
by the answer he just gave you say you
don't want an election and I can see why
you don't want an election because you
just lost your majority last time round
what's going wrong with the Conservative
Party and how does the party need to
change in order to win
I mean it's hugely complicated what's
happened remember I mean in my
constituency where yes by majority went
down and I'm no different from many
people actually who lost their seeds I
actually put on votes and we know that
we got more votes in the bag that we
didn't win the seeds and of course we
set out to win a large number of labour
seats to persuade people voted labour
before to vote conservative and what
happened and this is a dreadful thing to
have to say but it's true those people
were sitting on the edge if you like
they were prepared to vote conservative
but they needed a reason to vote
conservative the choice needed to be
well crafted for them and they they need
to take that step and actually vote
conservative they needed if you're like
a carrot something to persuade them that
our great public services would be
unharmed and in the under a Conservative
government our economy would be strong
and safe and of course there'd be real
hope and future for young people we
didn't do those things and actually what
we did was we offered up a load of
steaks I mean as she started to beat
people with those steaks and rather than
them actually voting conservative saying
at home they went back and they voted
labour and younger colony to cut your
fair voting labour thank you very much
and a Seabury for your thoughts